[MUSIC PLAYING]
APRIL ANDERSON: Welcome to part
two of our last episode
in this week's Women
Techmaker series.
It's been really rewarding for
us to talk to so many talented
women who are innovating in
the tech space this week.
And today, we're excited to
have yet another talented
woman techmaker, Hilary Mason,
who's the chief scientist at
bitly, joining us from
New York City.
Before we turn it over
to Hilary, by way of
introduction, my name's
April Anderson.
I'm an industry director
here at Google.
And I'm working to bring
Google's advertising solutions
to our top partners in
the retail market.
I've been at Google now for
about 10 years, and went to
school just down the road
at Stanford University.
I'm joined here by my colleague
Kathryn Hurley, who
I'll turn it over so she can
do a quick introduction.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Hey, everyone.
My name's Kathryn Hurley.
I'm a developer programs
engineer at Google.
And specifically, I work on
Google Compute Engine.
And as a developer programs
engineer, I help developers
use the Compute Engine API.
So for example, I write
sample code.
I speak at conferences.
You might have seen me
at London Strata
this year, for example.
And I answer questions on the
forum and Stack Overflow.
And prior to Google, I got a
master's in web science at the
University of San Francisco.
And so now, at this point, I'd
love to turn it over to
Hilary, so she can tell us a
little bit about herself and
give us a little bit about
her background.
HILARY MASON: Sure.
Hi.
First, thanks for inviting me.
It is really exciting to be
talking to both of you about
things I think we're all
pretty interested in.
So this is really cool.
And just to introduce myself
briefly, I'm Hilary Mason.
I'm the chief scientist
at bitly.
Bitly is a URL shortening
analytics company.
But the work we really do is
about understanding human
behavior through the lens
of social sharing.
So we look into the data
generated by our analytic
service and try and learn things
about humans, which is
pretty interesting.
Because my academic background
is in computer science, but my
whole life I've also
built things.
And so finally I'm in a position
where I'm both
building things and doing
interesting research.
I also co-founded a nonprofit
called hackNY that helps young
developers find interesting
opportunities in the NY
creative tech economy.
The tagline actually is from my
co-founder Chris Wiggins.
And we say, "to save kids
from the street," but
we mean Wall Street.
And I'm also involved in making
trouble in a bunch of
other ways in New York on Mayor
Bloomberg's advisory council.
And also, I'm a member of the
hackerspace NYC Resistor.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Wow, that is a
really awesome background.
You do a lot of amazing work.
So you briefly touched
upon bitly.
But do you mind going into a
little bit more detail about
what the company does, maybe
how it got started?
HILARY MASON: Sure.
So bitly was a total accident.
It was actually a feature of
another product that was a web
product around intellectual
discourse, around shared media
experiences.
But it totally failed.
But what did succeed was this
little piece of it for sharing
bits of content called bitly.
And we actually have a sister
company called Chartbeat that
uses some of the same
technologies.
And Chartbeat is real-time web
analytics for publishers.
So nobody really planned
bitly as a company.
It's not like someone woke up
one day and said, oh, I have a
great idea for the world's
best URL shortener.
But once that happened, we
started to build it.
And we realized that the
value would always
be in the data set.
And so eventually,
we developed a
business around that.
And that's our enterprise
analytics business where folks
who run large brands
are celebrities.
Basically, anyone who either
publishes a lot of content to
the social web or has a lot of
content about them published
to the social web pay us for
branding on their shortlinks.
And also, a whole set of
analytics about how their
stuff is doing.
So we have these two sides,
the data and the business.
And the work I do sort of
sits in the middle.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Very cool.
And how would you characterize
the bitly user experience?
For example, what do you think
that bitly is doing that
contributes to the seamless
content sharing
that we see on bitly?
HILARY MASON: Yeah, so bitly
is really the best way to
outsource your memory and the
content you want to save and
find later.
So you can go to bitly
as a consumer--
of course, it's all free.
And you can save things, tag
things, put notes on things.
And then you can find out how
many other people also saved
those things or were interested,
or clicked on
those things.
And you can come back and search
for that stuff later.
And you can share easily out
to many different networks.
So we see bitly as the hub that
sits between all of your
social sharing behavior.
APRIL ANDERSON: Hilary, I'm
really interested to learn
more about what it means
to be a data scientist.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about what that means?
What does a data scientist do?
And in your role as a chief
scientist at bitly, what does
your typical day look like?
Take us through that.
HILARY MASON: OK.
So those are two different
questions.
So I'll start with the one about
data science, which has
only really been around as a
profession for a few years.
And I'm pretty privileged to
consider myself part of the
larger worldwide conspiracy to
create the profession, or at
least help support it.
I think data science deserves
a new job title because it's
not anything that we've never
been able to do before.
But it's three behaviors that
we've never combined into one
professional before.
And those three behaviors are
first, being able to do math
and build models that represent
the real world.
The second one is being able to
write code or engineer the
systems that support
those models.
And sometimes to do it at
large scale as you guys
certainly do and as we do
at a scale as well.
And then third, to ask good
questions and be creative
enough to communicate
what you've
learned back to anybody.
And that's often the hardest
thing to find, especially
combined with someone who
knows math and is
an engineer as well.
But that's sort of the practice
that I've seen evolve
over the last couple years.
As to what I actually do, that's
a very good question.
I'm really privileged to work
with a brilliant team of
scientists, engineers,
and artists.
And my job is mainly to
coordinate the various
research questions that we're
investigating, the systems
we're working on, and to work
with our product and business
to prioritize our work
appropriately.
So I see our role as really
laying down the path where our
company will go in the next six
months or the next year.
APRIL ANDERSON: That's great.
And I definitely want to hear
more about that, but also want
to hear from Kathryn, who
has a few questions
for you on big data.
Because that's a very
interesting
topic for us as well.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Yes.
If you don't mind switching
gears a little bit.
So as a data scientist, you
work with lots of data.
What I'm first interested in
hearing about is what kind of
data is gathered by bitly
from your users.
HILARY MASON: So we primarily
see three kinds of data.
We see the save and
share events.
So if somebody shortens a link
or saves it in bitly.com, we
see the entire set of
clicks on that link
once it's shared out.
And that includes things like
the location of where people
are clicking on things from,
their referral, which social
network it's getting traffic
from, the user agent, so what
kind of device and
stuff like that.
And then we actually go
and crawl the full
content of each link.
And we would do a bunch of
analysis on that as well.
So we primarily work with those
three types of data.
KATHRYN HURLEY: OK.
That's some pretty interesting
data that you gather.
HILARY MASON: Definitely.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Yeah.
And just to give our audience an
idea of just how much data
bitly has and stores, and
how much data you get to
play with every day.
HILARY MASON: Yeah, so we see
tens of millions of links a
day, hundreds of millions of
clicks on those links, and
then a lot of content.
I don't remember off the top of
my head how big it is, but
it's moderately big.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Moderately
big?
It sounds pretty big to me.
And so that brings up
a good question.
A hot topic right
now is big data.
And I know you have an opinion
about big data because I
watched some of your talks.
What do you think
about big data?
HILARY MASON: So I think the
term "big data" is a little
difficult because it's
so hard to define.
So some people think big
data is when it won't
fit in Excel anymore.
And some people think big data
is when you need more than one
node to actually operate over
something or store it.
What I think is actually
fundamentally new and
interesting about big data is
that it reduces the friction
to working with data.
So it lets you ask a question
and get the answer back before
you've forgotten why you've
asked that question in the
first place.
So I think the advantages to
using these big-data type
technologies are really
human advantages.
They're not so much technical
advantages.
And I also, every so often, find
myself at a conference
with astrophysicists or people
who work in bioinformatics.
And they look at our data,
and they say, ha.
You thought that was big.
We had to invent a new kind of
hard drive to store our stuff.
So those are the people
who are really pushing
the edge of big data.
KATHRYN HURLEY: And so it
sounded like you have a couple
tools that you like to use
to work with big data.
Can you share what some
of those are?
HILARY MASON: Sure, though
they're fairly embarrassing
and old-fashioned.
My favorite way to work with
data whenever possible is on
the command line using the bash
tools, so grep and awk.
If you look on bitly's GitHub
page, we actually have some
nice scripts you can run to do
histograms on the command line
and do some really basic
sampling and get a sense of
your data just from that.
That's not always possible,
though, so I'm
a huge Python nerd.
We use NumPy, SciPy,
and scikit-learn.
We also do have a Hadoop
cluster here at bitly.
It's not my favorite piece
of infrastructure,
but we do use it.
And it works very well for
what we use it for.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Cool.
Thanks for sharing.
HILARY MASON: Of course.
KATHRYN HURLEY: And so working
with all this data, you
probably have a lot of insights,
make a lot of
interesting discoveries
with this data.
Can you share what your most
interesting discovery is with
all the bitly data?
HILARY MASON: It's really
hard to pick just one.
But one thing we put up on our
blog today was we looked at
the half-life of content
by topic.
And it turns out that most
content actually has very
similar half-lives.
And a half-life is the time it
takes for a link to get half
the clicks it'll ever get.
So just sort of looking at
how attention to it is
modified over time.
But one kind of content is much
shorter, and that's sports.
So once sports news is out of
date, nobody cares about it.
APRIL ANDERSON: That's
a point.
That's very true.
HILARY MASON: Not really a
surprise, but good to see it
proven in the data.
KATHRYN HURLEY: That's
so cool.
And you make these discoveries,
but how do they
actually influence bitly
as a product?
Do you see any changes in the
UI or in the back end?
Or are you just working with
the data and having fun?
HILARY MASON: Well, it's all
of the above, actually.
So we tend to ask a
research question.
And that might be something
like, can we build a model of
canonical social sharing?
So is there a consistent way
that content is shared through
different social networks?
And so we'll go out and
say, OK, how do we
know when we've won?
How do we know when we've done
that, when we've actually
answered that question?
And then two, is it scalable?
So can we actually build
a system to do this?
Most of our products are
real-time analytics products.
So is it possible to do
this in real-time?
And then, if so, what should
the product look like?
And so that question was
actually not hypothetical.
It was what we spent most
of last year working on.
And we actually released an
experimental product called
Realtime, which is at the domain
rt.ly, where you can go
in and look.
And it's showing you the stories
that are getting that
initial spike of attention.
And you can now go in and
see the actual maps of
attention over time.
So that's an example of
something that has gone from
research to infrastructure
to experiment.
And soon, to bitly product.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Awesome.
It's always fun to see the work
that you do get put into
the product, I think.
HILARY MASON: Absolutely.
We're also opening up some of
the APIs there as well, which
I'm pretty excited about.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Awesome.
I like APIs.
That's what I work
on every day.
All right, one more question
for you, and
then I'll hand it--
I feel like I'm hogging
the show.
But finally, have you hit
any walls recently?
Have you come across any
challenges with bitly's data?
And how have you overcome
those challenges?
HILARY MASON: So that's a
difficult question because I
think most of my time is spent
overcoming challenges.
And a lot of the time, they're
human challenges.
So somebody is after
something different
than what we're after.
Or we're not quite coordinated
within the company about what
we're trying to do.
And sometimes there are
technical challenges.
And I can think of examples
of both just from today.
One being that we defined some
key business metrics for one
of our apps.
And it turned out they were
getting written to one data
store and not another.
And so I spent a long time
trying to track that down.
In general, the ways I try to
work around these things are
to always talk to people
in a very positive way.
So not to get frustrated or
upset but rather to say, OK,
here's our problem.
How do we solve this problem?
And I'm really fortunate, again,
to work with a lot of
smart people who are
really nice.
In fact, our number one hiring
rule has always been, don't
hire assholes.
And so that tends to work
out pretty well.
KATHRYN HURLEY: That's
a good rule.
APRIL ANDERSON: Yes,
it's a good mantra.
So Hilary, I would love to hear
more about your role and
some of those challenges.
And also, some of those
opportunities as you work as
the chief scientist at bitly.
How do you really balance
wearing the technical hat and
the technical aspects of your
role with the things that are
more business-oriented?
HILARY MASON: That's a really
good question because it's
something I'm still learning
how to do.
And when I started at bitly
three years ago, I was writing
code every day.
We were such a small team
that everyone knew what
everyone was doing.
And it was pretty clear
where we were going.
We had only one thing to do,
and that was keep scaling.
And now we've got a couple of
different products, a larger
business, a lot more people.
And so it has been a challenge
to learn how to grow with the
company and to grow
my team from just
me to now nine people.
The ways I try to do that
are generally--
it sounds really trite, but
actually applying the
scientific method.
So even in product or business
problems saying,
OK, here's my theory.
What experiments can we do
given the data we have
available, or the people we
have available, or the
resources we have available
to answer this question?
Can we try something and see
what happens, and then try
something else?
And that is generally how I've
thought about the world.
And it has worked pretty well.
APRIL ANDERSON: That's great.
And how do you really infuse
that with your team?
This is an industry and
certainly a product that
requires constant iteration,
constant innovation.
How do you really foster that
creativity with your teams?
HILARY MASON: I try and
lead by example.
And what I mean there is to
have lots of bad ideas.
Because you have to have
a lot of ideas to
have any good ideas.
And if you don't even
try to articulate
those, the bad ones--
if you're afraid to do it
or you're going to be
embarrassed, then you're going
to miss out on the good ones.
Or when you say something that
might not be the best idea,
maybe one of your colleagues
can say, well,
that's total bullshit.
But this other twist on it
might actually work.
And so we try and keep that
kind of open environment.
And also, keep in mind that a
lot of the best ideas don't
come from our researchers
with PhDs in math.
They come from the people who
are working on our community
support team because they're
actually there working with
customers all the time.
And so within the company, we
try and create a culture that
ideas come from anywhere.
Questions can come
from anywhere.
No one should be afraid
to have bad ones
or ask silly questions.
Yeah, I do a lot of that.
APRIL ANDERSON: No, I think it's
something we all kind of
strive to do, right?
Keep that customer
voice infused in
everything that we do.
As a bit of a tangent on data,
I'd love to hear, how do you
actually keep track of your
own data within bitly?
When you get this kind of
feedback, what are the
mechanisms that you use to
really make sure that you're
keeping your finger on the pulse
of how the product's
doing and what the customers
are saying about it?
Your own sort of big
data, as it may be.
HILARY MASON: Right.
So one of our responsibilities
is the not so sexy area of
business analytics.
That is, even figuring out what
metrics correlate to the
kinds of behaviors
we want to see.
And for some things,
it's really easy.
So you have a certain amount
of money, and you
watch that go up.
And that's great, right?
Your problem's solved.
But for a lot of things,
it's not that simple.
So one of the projects I'm
working on is growing our
platform and working
on API design.
And we start to think about,
OK, what kind of platform
users do we want?
How do we want to understand
their behavior on our system?
On the technical side-- if there
are any technical folks
in the audience--
we have a consistent development
metaphor within
bitly for all our systems,
which is you
have a stream of data.
You have a queuing system.
You have queue readers that
read out of that queue.
You have some kind
of API layer.
And you have an application.
And what that lets us do is take
those streams of data and
put them in places where we
can analyze them pretty
easily, or hang things off of
them that can fire events when
metrics happen.
And so we track everything we
can in StatsD and Graphite.
We also have our own dashboard
called the Aquarium.
We're big on the fish theme.
And we just try and make that
available to everyone in the
company, so that anyone can ask
a question and find that
answer without having
to ask someone else.
APRIL ANDERSON: That's great
to have that transparency.
I would love to hear a
little bit more, too.
I mean, you are doing so
many things at bitly.
And you have such an impressive
background.
What do you think of your
early experiences really
prepared you most for
your current role?
And are there any sort of
experiences that you'd
recommend for people who are
really looking to build a
career in tech and leadership
within the tech space?
HILARY MASON: Yeah.
That's another good question.
So I have a mix of
experiences.
Some of them are theoretical
and academic.
And many of them were
much more--
so I really do like
video games.
So at one point, I built a
system to gather a lot of data
out of video games.
And then it turned out it
actually had commercial value.
But it was a total accident, and
I was pretty naive about
how I had developed it.
So my only advice there is that
you have to actually do
things and not be afraid to do
things that are not perfect.
If you do things and they're not
that great, people for the
most part just ignore them.
But if you do things and they're
really interesting--
and if you're interested in
something, there are other
people out there who are going
to be interested in it.
The second piece of advice--
and this is something I
learned probably a little bit
too late-- is that you need to
build a community.
And in New York, we've been
really fortunate to see huge
growth in the number of people
working in tech or in
companies that have a large tech
component over the last
five years.
But we've also done a lot to
build a data community here.
And we've gotten people from--
where I say "we," it's mostly
me and a few other people who
said, we want this to
exist in New York.
And we want New York
to have this voice.
So we went out and found
people who shared that
motivation and that interest and
just started introducing
them to each other.
And making sure that we have a
meetup every few months where
we get together with some
beers, so people
are a little relaxed.
And they can talk about what
they're working on or what
they're thinking about.
But that community is
really important.
APRIL ANDERSON: No,
that's great.
Thank you so much for
sharing that, too.
I think it is important to be
active and try new things and
really put yourself out there.
So it's great advice to give.
I'm going to turn it back over
to Kathryn because we want to
hear a little bit more also
about some of your recent
presentations and some of the
things that you've talked
about in terms of prioritizing
research.
HILARY MASON: Sure.
KATHRYN HURLEY: If we
have enough time.
So like I said, I was watching
some of your recent
presentations.
One in particular at Devs Love
Bacon, which is a very awesome
title for a conference.
And at that conference, you
talked about-- and sorry, I'm
reading off my notes here.
I just want to get the
question right.
So you talked about several
steps in the
data analysis process.
So that included finding,
scrubbing, exploring,
modeling, and interpreting
the data.
And so I was just curious if
you had any tips for data
scientists who are just starting
out in this data
analysis process.
And if you could, suggest any
tools or any kind of material
that could help them get
started in the field.
HILARY MASON: Sure.
Here So I have to say that I
love that you watched that
talk because I had given a
three-hour machine-learning
algorithm tutorial at a
conference the year before.
And the gentleman who organized
the BACON conference
attended and he liked it.
And so he said, will you
come to my conference
and give the talk?
And I said, sure, I'd love to.
And then when I got there,
he said, oh,
and you have 30 minutes.
And so I had this three-hour
tutorial planned.
And I was like, oh, oh, how do
I condense three hours of
material into something that'll
be entertaining and
interesting for 30 minutes and
actually not lose the value in
the presentation?
So that was an artifact of a lot
of stress and jet lag, but
I think it came out OK.
The process you talked
about is something--
it's from a document I co-wrote
with my colleague
Chris Wiggins, who's also a
co-founder of hackNY, a few
years ago now, where we realized
that there really was
no canonical statement of what
a data scientist does or even
how you look at data in
a non-scientific way.
And so we wrote this down.
And it is, indeed, this--
you get data.
You scrub it.
You model it.
You analyze it and you interpret
it, or make it
interpretable for
other people.
It's pretty simple and
seems obvious now.
But at the time, I hadn't seen
it written down like that.
So for young data scientists who
want to start to explore,
the first thing you
need is data.
And there's actually a lot
of data out there.
A lot of it's public data.
You can look at some of
the government data.
Even bitly has a public
data set of all
the 1.usa.gov clicks.
So we powered the federal
government URL shortener.
It's all public data.
It's a good way to play with
social data if you're
interested in that.
Or you can scrape it.
So a lot of people do that.
I just did a really fun little
side project where I scraped
all the menus for non-fast-food
restaurants in
New York City, and then tried to
plot clusters of different
restaurant types.
So I found Chinatown.
And I found where you should
go for Thai food.
It was all really to find better
cheeseburgers, which--
this has mostly worked.
But the data's out there.
And so if you can think of a
question you would ask if you
had some data.
Or the other way around, so find
some data and then look
at it and try and see what
stands out to you.
Then you can start looking
at different tools.
You can even start in Excel.
So it's sort of a dirty secret,
but a lot of people do
great work in Excel.
And when you move up from that,
you can go either to R
if you're a statistician by
training or Python if you're
more a computer scientist.
Load that data up.
And especially if you're in an
environment like IPython with
the interactive notebook, you
can start graphing it and
tweaking things and seeing
what you can find there.
And then, my next recommendation
is get a GitHub
account and put whatever
you did up there.
And then let people tell
you why it's wrong.
Because you will learn a lot,
and they will think it's cool.
And you'll get a lot of good
feedback and start to meet
people who are also interested
in what you're interested in.
KATHRYN HURLEY: And you create
a lot of cool visualizations
as well with the data.
So are there any libraries that
you like to use to create
these visualizations?
HILARY MASON: Well, at bitly,
we are huge fans of D3.js.
In fact, my colleague Mike Dewar
wrote a short O'Reilly
book on getting started
with D3.
So if you'd like to check
that out, we use it on
our Realtime site.
And it's a really good book.
Otherwise, so data visualization
in the service
of usefulness, where it really
doesn't have to be pretty, I
still mostly use matplotlib in
Python, which is a very simple
way to make fairly uninteresting
graphs.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Cool.
All right, maybe one
more question?
OK.
And then I just want to ask
about the prioritizing
research blog post that
you wrote recently.
So people that might not be
familiar with it, I'll just
cover it real quick.
So you have five different
steps for
prioritizing research.
And that's you first
state a question.
Then you ask yourself, how do
you know when you've won?
And correct me if I'm not
getting these right, please.
Then you assume the question
was answered correctly.
What are the first things that
you're going to build with it?
And then, if everyone in
the world uses it--
let's see--
how does that change
human behavior?
And the last one, my favorite
one, is, what's the most evil
thing that can be
done with this?
So first, my question is, what
about that last question?
Why did you include that?
HILARY MASON: I included that
because it lets you turn the
work upside down and think about
the implications of what
you're doing in a really
creative way.
And just getting people to
brainstorm about how they
could do something terrible with
what they're working on
really makes them think
about it in a new way.
And we've had a lot of really
good ideas come out of that.
I do want to add that
we're not evil.
We're generally trying to build
very good things, sort
of build things that make the
world more like the world we
want to live in.
But that question tends to get
people to think creatively
about the research in
a way that nothing
else I've found works.
APRIL ANDERSON: That's great.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Cool.
APRIL ANDERSON: I think
we're wrapping.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Yes, I
think we'll wrap up.
So I just want to say thank
you so much, Hilary, for
joining us.
It was--
HILARY MASON: Oh,
thank you, both.
This was super fun.
APRIL ANDERSON: Yeah,
it was really nice
to meet you, Hilary.
Thank you so much for sharing.
I'm fascinated and very much
inspired by all the work that
you've done in your
career thus far.
So thank you for coming here.
HILARY MASON: Likewise.
And thank you for hosting.
APRIL ANDERSON: Absolutely.
KATHRYN HURLEY: That's great.
Learning so much great
information from you.
And I guess, should I wrap up?
Sorry.
And to our viewers, thank you
so much for joining us for
this final episode of the
Women Techmaker series.
And all of our programming can
be viewed and shared on
Google+ or Google
Developers Live.
Tell us what you think about
this series by hashtagging
your comments with WTM.
And keep an eye out for more
Women Techmakers and Google
Developers Live events.
Thanks.
APRIL ANDERSON: Thanks,
everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]